[Music]
I'm Dana Jacobson from CBS Saturday
morning welcome to the dish a little
extra dash of flavor or some sauce on
the side can be a great compliment to
any meal so for this episode seasoning
and condiments are King we'll travel to
the birthplace of ranch dressing and
learn the secrets behind a traditional
Chinese topping chili crisp but we start
in Baltimore Maryland where a once
humble spice blend has become a popular
seasoning on all sorts of foods here's
Major Garrett
thank you what's inside a can of Old Bay
turns out there's a lot inside that red
yellow and blue tin more than just a
spicy salty Smoky seasoning blend that's
in part because of Ralph Brun well my
father started the spice company in
Baltimore in 1939. Gustav Bron Ralph's
dad fled Nazi Germany for Baltimore in
the late 30s he had spent actually 16
days and it's prior to coming here in a
concentration camp sounds like a narrow
Escape we got out it was a touch and go
situation Ralph was 14 when he and his
family arrived with little money and
fewer prospects a father looked for a
job and couldn't find one and ultimately
somebody told him well you got your
equipment here could get a business
right and he did he bought this Mill in
1935. the equipment was an industrial
spice grinder brought over from Germany
so Central to the Old Bay story it is on
display at the Baltimore Museum of
Industry this machine doesn't make it to
America there is no Old Bay that is true
this is what started Old Bay seasoning
at the time Gustav made and sold spices
mostly to Meat Packers for things like
sausages hot dogs and baloney his place
of operation was directly across the
street from the a wholesale Fish Market
which existed there at the time in
downtown Baltimore and that's how old
Bay found its way into the seafood you
eat today fishmongers would buy Gustav
spice mix to steam crabs primarily the
English red pepper used black pepper
mustard celery seeds so that sort of
thing Ralph eventually took over the
company before selling it to a British
firm spice giant McCormick owns Old Bay
now
not surprisingly around a crab Ralph
Brun is a maestro no no no you don't do
that correspondent not so much email he
would be tolerated in Maryland keep that
up for some Old Bay is nostalgic woven
into Mid-Atlantic augusts of yesteryear
it takes me back to the warm weather
takes me back to the beginning of Summer
and if you haven't noticed Old Bay is
seemingly everywhere these days printed
on shoes aprons bandanas shirts infused
into goldfish hot sauce beer and yes
vodka
Greg David is CEO of Georgia's beverage
company which took three years to
develop Old Bay vodka now sold in the
Mid-Atlantic the first batch produced
600 cases it sold out in 24 minutes
we've done almost 10 000 cases
since the middle of March the same is
true of Old Bay goldfish also sold out
in record time
did you ever imagine a situation where
this creation of your fathers and your
families would become this sort of
runaway brand that it's become no I had
no idea it would do that and of course I
wish my father were alive today in order
to see this because he was proud of this
was his baby his father would also want
to pay a visit to the charmery in
Baltimore where Old Bay caramel ice
cream is a menu staple that's amazingly
good and I'm not alone you can feel the
peppery tingling I expected it to you
know taste like the Old Bay Seasoning
but it didn't have that it was very
smooth actually amid the Old Bay Mania
Ralph Brun is a voice of reason a
reality check on seasonal spice swooning
can you love this too much I think when
they get carried away with having all
these old Bays or something the other
that you're talking about I think it's
ridiculous but that's what they do it's
a seasoning that's all it is
coming up we take a look at one of the
most popular condiments in the world
we'll catch up with you right after the
break
[Music]
found on Burgers dogs fries and so much
more ketchup Reigns supreme but where
would the delightful dip originate Luke
Burbank takes us from the Heinz Brands
tomato fields in Northern California to
Hot Dog joints in Chicago to learn more
about what you could call the king of
condiments
ketchup is just one of those American
things so common
so typical
so ubiquitous that most of us never give
it a second thought
it has everything that you could want
it's sweet and sour it's got vinegar in
it it's got sugar in it Andrew Smith is
a food historian who says ketchup
actually started out in what is now
considered Indonesia as a sort of fish
sauce called quetzia
British colonists brought it home and
then in the 19th century it landed here
where there was an overabundance of
tomatoes if you had ton of tomatoes in
September or October he had to do
something with them and one of the
things that you could do with them is
make ketchup it took off immediately due
to its ability to add flavor to things
and we mean everything during the
Depression people would go into small
diners and they would order a glass of
water and then they would pick up the
ketchup and they would add the ketchup
and they would have tomato juice at the
end it's not bad put a little vodka in
there a couple of olives and the man may
be most responsible for ketchup's spread
was a young german-american businessman
in Pittsburgh named Henry J Heinz he
started out selling horseradish with
limited success but it was his tomato
ketchup that really took off so we're
out in a tomato field in the middle of
California this this is a tomato field
that contains 4707 our Workhorse Heinz
variety Troy Shannon works for Heinz
this tomato is exactly right for ketchup
it's much thicker and less juicy than a
normal tomato that you buy in a grocery
store the 4707 has actually been
patented by Heinz the result of years of
research and development
[Applause]
and after those four 707s are picked
they become the responsibility of Hector
osorno tomato ketchup master
really that's his title and he knows the
secret recipe
have they told you what's in the spices
yes so they trust you with that
information yes but you can't tell me no
osorno is one of only seven ketchup
Masters at Heinz and sometimes what we
do is just check charged with
maintaining The Taste color and
consistency of all
650 million bottles sold each year oh
wow
gonna try it yeah
I'm gonna just do this oh okay
it's good you did
but one place his ketchup Mastery won't
be necessary Chicago at least not when
it comes to Hot Dogs no ketchup no
ketchup anything else but no ketchup
it's like sacrilegious fresh chopped
onions step behind the counter at
Portillo's a kosher dill Spiller and
you'll see that's Chicago style hot dogs
aren't hurting for flavor is there a
strategy to eating a Chicago style dog
some folks take the pickle off and eat
the pickle on the side some folks just
grab it and dig right in and eat it as
it is
and don't even think about asking for
ketchup across town
at the legendarily Saucy wieners Circle
can I have ketchup on there hecky no we
don't think that's against the rules of
a queen and circle we don't do ketchup
and hot dogs okay not in Chicago either
no and it turns out she wasn't kidding
thank you thank you now go sit down and
have us okay eat it out
no ketchup man
well I had to try
a chili crisp once a relatively rare
traditional Chinese topping has recently
undergone a Renaissance in the United
States and around the world you can find
it on dumplings of course but also
everything from Pizza to ice cream Nancy
Chen has more
crunchy and textured I love that Sizzle
a bright Collision of chilies and spices
simmered in oil smells really good
Chinese chili crisp isn't spicy hot but
the condiment is on fire
long ladled onto classic Asian dishes
like dumplings noodles and stir fries
chili crisp is exploding in popularity
even expanding to the dessert menu
is there anything you can't put it on I
have yet to find something you can't put
it on if it's edible you can put it on
Chef and flyby Jing CEO Jing GAO adds
her unique spin to the traditional
topping by sourcing 18 ingredients
exclusively from her hometown in Citron
China red chilies that are fruity mild
heat super fragrant the high quality
ingredients from chundu including
Sichuan pepper and fermented black beans
aren't readily available elsewhere but
gal gave us an idea how they all come
together in her Los Angeles kitchen what
is the appeal here is it the spiciness
the texture there's something about it
you can't really put your finger on but
somehow it just works with everything
right it is basically just the
components of chilies and oil but when
you add in those extra layers that's
what gives the chili crisp the extra
dimension of flavor and now the flavors
are infused into the oil families in
China have enjoyed their own time on
honored recipes that's maputofu right
there yes but it became widely
commercialized when a Chinese noodle
maker bottled and branded her version
log and Ma now produces more than a
million jars a day for fans in more than
30 countries we're playing a part in
preserving that tradition by pushing it
Forward by introducing it to New
audiences a culture and a tradition if
it doesn't evolve it dies so we want to
play a part in evolving it in our own
way after
GAO opened a restaurant in Shanghai
focused on locally sourced ingredients
before traveling the world as a chef in
pop-up kitchens for a very long time
people had not just a lack of awareness
about what Chinese cuisine was but also
additional bias against it like that
it's oily that is oily that it's
unhealthy that it's low quality and
should be cheap right and so if those
are the attitudes that people have
towards Chinese cuisine then there's no
incentive for anybody to really bring
anything of quality out it's about more
than just the food too when you talk
about those perceptions absolutely in
2018 gal launched a viral Kickstarter
campaign to fund her own signature chili
crisp
and with more people cooking at home
during the pandemic her company has
grown tenfold
the U.S chili crisp craze isn't limited
to store shelves and kitchen counters
restaurants are also making it their own
that's two really good things together
same Brooklyn pizza maker Paulie G
recently partnered with family-run Xi'an
Famous Foods for a pie centered around
their secret recipe made up of three
fragrant spices this is Xi'an Famous
Pizza what do the chili crisps add to
this texture
even with more than 50 pizzas on the
menu G says this one quickly became a
hit after its debut
we're eating pizza that's made out of an
oven that came from Italy and it's using
spice that is inspired by something that
people in China have been eating for
centuries and it's all made here in
America
there's the conversation about Chinese
food to elevate its status in our
culture so we're really here to uplift
all marginal ice cultures not just
Chinese and we're doing so through
flavor a Melting Pot of taste melding
together tradition and Innovation I have
made a version of a Mezcal Paloma
there's a rim of Mala spice oh and then
a little bit of the chili Chris oil well
cheers
coming up a trip to the Hidden Valley
pretty sure you know what condiment
we're referring to next on the dish
one of the most popular brands of ranch
dressing Hidden Valley began in the
mountains near Santa Barbara California
Luke Burbank went there to get the story
behind the creamy concoction
amazing Place Hidden Valley if you
turned on the TV in the 1980s or 90s
there was one place where the hills were
always green and life seemed a little
simpler here in Hidden Valley freshness
is a way of life ah yes Hidden Valley
Ranch America's first and most popular
ranch salad dressing The Squeeze on the
Hidden Valley Ranch
and it turns out Hidden Valley Ranch was
an actual place albeit a very different
looking one from the bottles in the
mountains outside of Santa Barbara
Hidden Valley was Chaparral
it was wild California this is the ranch
Allen Barker remembers the ranch and its
owner Steve Henson well Steve had an
artistic truth in the sense that he told
people what they wanted to hear
a fast-talking plumber who made it big
in Alaska Henson had a bigger dream of
owning a ranch which he knew he would
call Hidden Valley there was a bare rug
in front of a fireplace
he had I don't know how many tales about
how he had killed this bear in Alaska
the truth of the matter was he found the
bear rug at the County dump
as a teen Barker lived with the Henson
family and worked at the so-called Ranch
I wouldn't call it a ranch in reality
there were no animals there were no
crops you know it was a motel in the
mountains a motel that didn't have all
that many customers but what it did have
was Steve Henson's homemade salad
dressing which he called Ranch he was
trying to make a low-calorie substitute
for blue cheese for my memory it was
buttermilk Miracle Whip some spices and
I think some chopped up shallots and
then the ingredient that was Kept Secret
pure MSG
Hidden Valley ultimately failed as a
motel but exploded as a mail order mix
your own salad dressing business which
The Henson sold to Clorox in 1972 when
you're tasting prototypes of ranch there
is a threshold after about six seven
eight prototypes we really have to kind
of take a break there's our pan Laurie
Welborn a Brit who never even tried the
stuff until adulthood is in charge of
how it all tastes he's the head of r d
for hvr as it's called by people in the
know it is a dip and it is a dressing
this is the thing it's versatile it's
also something you can cook with we've
even seen all super fans bathing in
Hidden Valley Ranch at times
these days over on Tick Tock ranch
dressing is less of a salad dressing and
more of a personality type
[Music]
in fact well-born claims that Ranch now
outsells ketchup in America
quite the accomplishment for a salad
dressing invented by a plumber at a
failed Motel
with a made-up name all right Cheers
Cheers
getting notes of a valley
seems hidden
a ranch of some kind
more stories like this and live coverage
of breaking news 24 7 stream us right
here on CBS News I'm Dana Jacobson we'll
see you next time for another helping of
the dish
episode of the dish is sponsored by
Prudential plan invest insure retire
with Prudential